the nominees for performance by an  actress in a leading role are  marie-christine Barrault in Kazan Kuzon  Faye Dunaway in network Talia Shire in  Rocky  Liv Ullmann in face-to-face  and the winner is Faye Dunaway in  network  you  well I didn't expect this happen quite  yet but I do thank you very much  and I'm very grateful I would like  especially to thank Sidney Lumet paddy  Chayefsky Howard got freed Danny Melnick  and the great generosity of a rare group  of actors company of actors in  particular William Holden Robert Duvall  and Peter Finch and may I just add and a  special thank you to the friends in the  backroom Susan Germaine and Lee Herman  thank you